The Divine Comedy
is the greatest literary masterpiece
in human history.
When Dante wrote it
in about 1300,
he called it La Commedia.
Okay?
And the reason why is that
at this time in history,
epic poetry was considered high, okay?
Or tragic.
And it was written usually in Latin.
But for Dante, what he really believed
is that epic poetry should be
democratic. It should be accessible to
the people. That's why he called it La
Commedia, low, okay?
Which
meant comedy.
And so he wrote it in Tuscan, which is
the language of Florence, where he
lived.
>> [sighs]
>> Um Latin was the language of the elite
in Europe. He wanted to write in Tuscan
so that ordinary people around him could
access it.
And as a result, Dante is
a great
believer in democracy. So, uh
Homer,
Dante,
and Shakespeare
were in their own respective languages
the greatest poets.
Because first and foremost, they
believed that poetry
should be accessed by the people. They
believed in um a democratic spirit to
poetry. And that made them distinct from
the people of their time.
La Commedia is response then to the
Aeneid
by Virgil.
At [snorts] this time in history, for
the past 1,000 years, the Aeneid was a
dominant dominant literature in Europe.
And it was the foundation for the
Catholic Church.
Okay? So remember when we read the
Aeneid, the Aeneid is fundamentally
about duty,
uh piety.
Um and it just opposed and and it
contrasted love.
Okay? And this became the dominant idea
in the Catholic Church, where
you are not allowed to access God.
You're not allowed to believe in love.
You must obey the church because only
the church can guarantee you redemption
and salvation. And this, of course, led
to massive corruption
in the Catholic Church.
But it also led to wars throughout
Europe because so much power was
concentrated in the Catholic Church. And
as a result, many kings fought over um
for power in the Catholic Church.
And this led to
many wars. It led also to a splintering
of the Catholic Church. And Dante found
himself embroiled into a lot of these
conflicts. Okay? So he wrote La Commedia
in order to have people access God.
Okay? For the for the comedy, you can
access God and bypass Catholic Church.
In fact, if you read La La Commedia,
you'll find there are a lot of direct
criticisms of the Catholic Church.
Also, La Commedia was written in
response to the Aeneid. And like Homer,
what Dante wanted to do is position love
first and foremost, okay? In La
Commedia, love is God itself.
All right. So these are the basic themes
that we'll be looking at um throughout
this book. So let me talk about the
structure of La La Commedia. All right?
There are three distinct parts.
First is Inferno.
>> [snorts]
>> Second is Purgatory.
And the last is Paradise.
>> [sighs and gasps]
>> And what makes um the
La Commedia so powerful is Dante uses
two major literary literary devices
to construct his universe. The first is
what we call structure.
The second is paradox.
All right?
So imagine La Commedia as not just epic
poetry, but as a very complex
mathematical puzzle that you must
unravel through time.
Okay? So um Inferno, the structure is an
inverted triangle.
And so what's going to happen is that
Dante and Virgil Virgil are going to um
tra uh travel through Inferno, through
hell, but it's almost like they're
traveling underground,
okay? It's an inverted triangle.
And then Purgatory becomes a pyramid or
a mountain.
Where Dante and Virgil are going to
travel up a mountain so that they can
meet Beatrice at the very top. And why
they will meet Beatrice at the very top
is that Beatrice will take um Dante to
heaven, where he will meet God. And that
is the very ending
of the Divine Comedy, okay? La Commedia.
And in Paradise, it is structured as um
a
solar system.
And here is something called the
Empyrean, where God is. And then Dante
will travel with Beatrice into the
Empyrean. And it's structured like a
uh solar system, okay? So that's the
very structure of the Divine Comedy. And
as you can see, it's very mathematical.
>> [snorts]
>> It's rigorous if it's mathematical.
There's a symmetry to the the La
Commedia that doesn't really exist
anywhere else in poetry. But what makes
Divine Comedy so distinct and so
powerful is the idea of paradox or maybe
dissonance.
Call it dissonance.
And so
all poetry is designed to be memorized.
It's all designed to be read aloud.
And there are subtlety and nuance in all
poetry. And the reason why is think of
poetry as almost like a virus. And what
it what it's trying to do is it's trying
to infiltrate you. It's trying to
subvert you. It's trying to remake you.
Okay? And that's what the Divine Comedy
does, where you read it and it all
sounds very simple and nice. But the
more you memorize it, the more you
interact with it, the more it enters you
and it creates cognitive dissonance.
Meaning that it is disrupting the normal
way you see the world. It creates
paradox. What's going to happen is that
your mind is going to by itself
subconsciously try to unravel these
paradoxes over time.
Okay? So the more you read the Divine
Comedy over decades, the more it will
reveal itself to you.
It is a universe that comes into you and
then it remakes you.
Okay? And that is the power and beauty
of the Divine Comedy. So the trick is to
unravel the paradoxes, uh which will
implant themselves throughout the Divine
Comedy. Okay. So
what um
So another thing about the structure is
that in order to reach Paradise,
Dante must first
enter Inferno, okay? And there are
different ways you can interpret the
meaning of this.
The simplest way to interpret this is
that in order to really truly discover
God, you must experience hell yourself.
Okay? So good and evil are
um
are intertwined together. You can never
have good unless you first experience
evil.
Good is not the absence of evil. Good is
the confrontation and the defeat of
evil. Okay?
That's one possible way to interpret it.
But another way to interpret interpret
it is that Inferno represents Virgil,
uh which represents the Aeneid.
And so for Dante to begin the process of
entering into heaven, he must first
recognize the impact of Virgil and the
Aeneid on his psyche, on his culture.
And then by recognizing this, defeat the
Aeneid in order to fully embrace um the
power of God and of love, okay? And And
that's the interpretation that I want I
want I want to present to you as we go
along.
All right.
Okay.
So um
having gone that, let's go over some
basic biography. Uh this is Dante. And
Dante is considered the greatest poet in
the Italian in Italian language. At this
time in history, Italy was divided into
city-states. So um Dante was in
Florence,
but there are also some major city
states like Venice and Genoa.
Okay? [snorts] And they're all competing
against each other. They're also
competing against Rome,
okay, the Catholic Church,
which wanted to exert authority over
these city states. At the same time, you
had uh the different empires of Europe,
for example, France
and basically the Holy Roman Empire,
which we would today call Germany.
And they're also trying to exert
authority over
uh these city states. At the same time,
there are different factions within
these states city states, different
families that fight against each other.
So, during Dante's time, and this this
again is about the year 1300,
he is experiencing constant [snorts]
conflict, constant violence, constant
hatred. And for him, the major question
is, how can we as a people, as humans,
escape this constant cycle of vengeance
and hatred and war? And that's why he
wrote the Divine Comedy.
Um two major bio biographical details
that you need to understand about him is
that he is of noble birth and therefore
he he's a participant in uh this
conflict. So, uh the northern Italian
city states, which include Florence,
Milan,
um
uh Genoa, and Venice, they have two
major political factions, okay? This is
Wikipedia, by the way, all right?
Uh the Guelphs,
which support the papacy, and the
Ghibellines, which support the Holy
Roman Empire. Okay? So, Dante's family
belongs to the Guelphs. So, he was just
born into this political rivalry, and
over time, what will happen is that the
Guelphs will win, but then the Guelphs
will divide into the black and white uh
factions. So, different families
fighting for power again, okay? So, all
of Dante's all his life he's experienced
nothing but political rivalry and
hatred. That's the first major thing you
need to know about him. Ultimately, what
will happen is that he'll get sick of
this um constant fighting and he will
exile himself to focus on his poetry.
The other thing to know about him is he
falls in love with Beatrice
at a very early age, okay? Um he he
meets her when she is nine and she is
eight. The problem is that Beatrice's
family is of more noble aristocratic
birth than Dante. Now, at this time in
history, all marriages are arranged, and
so Dante marries someone of his class,
Beatrice marries someone of of his
class, but they never really
um
abandon each other, okay? They they
still remain friends, and Dante in his
heart still has this longing for
Beatrice.
Beatrice will die pretty young, maybe
when she's in her mid-20s, she'll die
giving birth, but Dante never for-
forgets about her, and he spends his
entire life still remembering his love
for Dante for Beatrice, and this becomes
the basis of the Divine Comedy, okay? La
Commedia.
Um so, these are the two major biograph-
uh
biographical details you need to know
about Dante.
Okay. So, um again, this is um
um
from Wikipedia, and
when Dante's exiled from Florence, okay?
He never returns to Florence. He spends
all his life in the exile. He becomes
patronized by some very powerful
aristocrats throughout um Italy, and he
will spend his a lot of his time
reflecting on his experience in this
political faction. In the Divine Comedy,
there will be a lot of references to
this conflict between the Ghibellines
and the Guelphs and his exile from
Florence and his hatred of the Catholic
Church. Um there will also be a lot of
references to his love for Beatrice,
which will redeem him from this earthly
conflict, okay?
All right. So,
some passages that we've looked at in um
before, but which I want us to
emphasize, okay? To to understand the
Divine Comedy. All right, so let's let's
let's look at some passages, okay? So,
um
Uh Aubrey, could you read for me,
please?
When I had journeyed half of our life's
way, I found myself within a shadowed
forest, for I had lost the path that
does not stray.
Uh it is hard to speak of what it was,
that savage forest, dense and difficult,
which even in recall renews my fear.
So bitter, death is hardly more severe.
But to retell the good discovered there,
I'll also tell the other things I saw.
Okay. So, he's saying, right, this is
the very beginning of the Divine Comedy.
This is the Allen Mandelbaum
translation, okay?
>> [snorts]
>> And I choose Allen Mandelbaum. There are
lots of um
other
um translations because he's just the
easiest to read.
All right? So, I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
not interested in the language, I'm
interested in the ideas.
So, that's why I pick him, okay? So,
this is very simple.
He is in a middle age and he's in a
shadowed forest, okay? So, he's
completely confused
um as to why the world is what it is.
This hatred for the world is um causing
him to hate himself as well.
And so, because of this hatred,
because of this confusion about why
there's so much hatred in the world,
he has lost his connection with God.
Um and he doesn't know how to proceed.
It's a long period, a savage forest,
dense and difficult, that
makes him question everything, okay?
He's in a deep depression, basically.
And and at this point, he is lost in
this forest and he feels hopeless, and
then a man emerges named Virgil.
And Virgil is the poet that Dante
respects the most because at this point
in history, Virgil is the most
influential poet.
And Virgil promises to guide Dante out
of the shadowed forest and into the
light, and Dante puts his faith in
Virgil. And at this point, Dante sees
Virgil not just as a savior, but as a
father and a as a teacher, okay?
This is important because for Dante to
truly defeat Virgil, which is the point
of La Commedia, he wants to destroy the
influence and power of the Aeneid, he
first must put Virgil onto a pedestal
pedestal in order for us to recognize
the limitations of Virgil so that we
ourselves can defeat Virgil in our
hearts. Okay? And that's the idea here.
All right. Uh can can you continue uh
Aubrey?
All right.
Yeah, keep on going.
In heaven, there is a gentle lady, one
who weeps for the distressed wards which
I send you to so that stern judgment of
above is shattered.
And it was she who called upon Lucia,
requesting of her,
"Now your faithful one has need of you,
and I commend him to you."
Lucia, enemy of every cruelty, arose and
made her way to where I was, sitting
beside the venerable Rachel.
She said, "You, Beatrice, true praise of
God, why have you not helped him when
who loves you so that for your sake he
sought the vulgar crowd?
Do you not hear the anguish in his cry?
Do you not see the death he wars against
upon that river ruthless as the sea?
No one within this world has ever been
so quick to seek his good or flee his
harm as I." When she had finished
speaking thus,
"To come below, down from my blessed
station,
I trusted in your honest utterance,
which honors you and those who listen to
you."
When she had finished with her words to
me, she turned aside her gleaming,
tearful eyes, which only made me hurry
all the more. Okay. So, a lot of La
Commedia Divine Comedy is dialogue,
okay? There's a speaker and there's a
listener.
>> [clears throat]
>> And
this is an important formulation
um because what Dante wants us is to
recognize
is that when a speaker speaks, he or
she's speaking from a certain worldview,
a certain prejudice. And so, we must
always be on guard. We al- we must
always ask ourselves why this person is
saying what he or she is saying, okay?
So, um something that we discussed a lot
is the idea of God, okay? And God
is the perfect manifestation of love, of
generosity, of forgiveness.
And one thing that God does not do is
reciprocity.
Okay?
So,
the Catholic Church teaches you that if
you obey God, then God will allow you
access to heaven. And what Dante wants
us to understand is that cannot be true.
If God is perfection, if God is love, if
God is beauty, God would never require
anything of you.
God will always give you free will.
And free will and reciprocity are
contradiction,
okay?
If I make you do something in order to
access heaven, that means I don't give
you free will. But God
will give you free will.
All right? But here we can see a
contradiction, a paradox, in that what
it So, what's happening is that Dante is
talking to Virgil and Dante is asking
Virgil, "How did you get here? Why are
you here? Why are you taking me to
heaven?" And Virgil's response is,
"Well, I was having a very nice time
sitting in
home in limbo in hell, but then an
angel, Beatrice, came to me and said she
might help in order to help a friend."
And then Dante is like, "Okay, but why
would Beatrice want to help me?" And
then Virgil is like, "Well, because she
saw your pain in in heaven and she
recognizes
how much you love her.
And so,
Lucia said to her, 'You, Beatrice, why
don't you help him who loves you so
much?'"
Okay? So, it's almost like
a reciprocity where because Dante loves
Beatrice so much, Beatrice has to come
help him now.
But this goes against the very idea of
God, okay?
So, what's happening here is two
possibilities. The first possibility is
that Virgil is just lying.
Okay? But he's not really lying. He's
just He's just misinterpreting what's
going on.
God will always come to you if you truly
want God to come.
Okay? Because God is all generous. And
so, Dante is his heart is calling out
for God and God sends Beatrice without
any conditions.
And God sends Beatrice because God
understands that Beatrice is a person
who can most help Dante, okay? There's
no reciprocity here.
But when Beatrice tells Virgil this,
Virgil misinterprets this idea to mean
that there's reciprocity going on, okay?
So, it's not It's not really lying, but
it shows you the limitations
of Virgil's worldview, where in the
Aeneid it's all about reciprocity.
Okay? It's all about contract. It's all
about duty.
Okay? So, that's the first possibility.
But another possibility is that Beatrice
understands the limitations of Virgil
and so just tells Virgil what he wants
to hear or structures this in a way that
Virgil can understand, okay? Because if
Beatrice says to
Virgil, "I came to help Dante because
Dante needs help."
Virgil will be like, "Well, okay, he
needs help, but why help him?" And so
Beatrice doesn't want to spend time
explaining to him that the universe is
all forgiving.
So, so she just says, "Okay, well, it's
because he helped me in the past. It's
because of his love for me that I'm able
to go to heaven." Okay?
All right? So, already
in the beginning, we have to question
the authority of Virgil, okay? Virgil is
an unreliable
guide.
And for us to truly enter paradise, for
us to truly discover God, we need to
recognize he is unreliable ourselves.
Dante will never tell us, but he'll give
us clues to suggest that he is
unreliable. And we must reject him if we
are to fully embrace God. Okay?
All right, let's continue.
All right.
All right, so Virgil is taking Dante
into hell. And Virgil emphasizes Dante,
"This is the path that we must take if
we are to go into paradise. You must
first confront evil. You must first
understand sin for you to truly
understand goodness."
Okay? All right. And so, when they get
there, there's a river that blocks their
path into hell, and there is a ferryman
named Charon from Greek mythology who
will take them across [clears throat]
the
river, but the problem is that Dante is
still living. And Charon sees that and
he says to Dante,
"Well, there's a problem here. I can't
take you across because you're a living
soul and you're not dead. So, I can't
give you access to hell
Okay? All right, can you read, Ivory?
And here, advancing towards us in a
boat, an aged man, his his hair was
white with years, was shouting,
"Woe to you, corrupted souls.
Forget your hope of ever seeing heaven.
I come to lead you to the other shore,
to the eternal dark, to fire and frost.
And you approaching there, you living
soul, keep well away from these. They
are the dead."
But when he saw I made no move to go, he
said,
"Another way, in other harbors, will not
here will bring you passage to your
shore. A lighter craft will have to
carry you."
My guide then,
"Charon, don't torment yourself. Our
passage has been willed above, where one
can do what he has willed and ask no
more."
Now silence fell upon the woolly cheeks
of Charon, pilot of the livid marsh,
whose eyes were ringed about with wheels
of flame. Okay, so Charon doesn't want
to take Dante across because Dante is
still living.
But when Virgil says to him, "Hey, let
us pass." Charon
obeys, okay?
And this is a paradox.
So, let me explain the paradox to you.
Again, the thing about Dante is that
he's so subtle.
And it's written in a perfect manner.
So, the more you try to understand
what's going on, the more truth will be
revealed to you. So, the paradox is
this.
They are in hell and they are in hell
because they rejected God, okay? And the
And how we know that we we rejected God
is this sentence, "Woe to you, corrupted
souls. Forget your hope of ever seeing
heaven." Okay? So, So, you can interpret
this as saying that Charon is saying to
you is saying to people, "This is all
hopeless." Okay? But another way of
interpreting this is Charon Charon is
saying to all these souls, "You are here
because you believe God has abandoned
you. You believe there is no God. You
believe there is no heaven. You believe
you deserve to be here, that's why
you're here." Okay?
Um
So, that But then he sees Dante and he
he knows that Dante doesn't believe
this. He is actually going to heaven.
And so, Dante is a corruption. And so,
Charon doesn't want to take Dante
across. But then Virgil says, "Hey,
God has ordered
Dante to be crossed." And then Charon
obeys. The problem The paradox is this.
Charon himself doesn't believe in God,
that's why he's in hell. He rejects the
authority of God. Yet he obeys God.
So, that makes actually no sense. This
is a paradox.
Unless you remember that what matters is
the speaker, okay? So, Virgil
is the one who is speaking.
Okay? So, in other words, Charon is not
obeying the authority of God, he's
obeying the authority of the speaker,
who is Virgil. And this suggests to us
that Virgil is the master of hell.
And then the question then is, "Well,
why is he master of hell?" And the
answer is because he created hell
through the Aeneid.
Right? Aeneid is a poetry that
emphasizes piety, obedience.
It emphasizes
how love is a disease. It emphasizes the
the importance of hatred as a power to
destroy your enemies. It emphasizes
empire.
So, in other words, Virgil, through the
Aeneid, created emotions in human in
human beings that allow for the creation
of hell itself. You can also argue that
with the Aeneid, Virgil created the
conditions for the Catholic Church. The
Catholic Church is not based on the
Bible, it's based on the Aeneid. Okay?
So, again,
this is not apparent
in the poetry. But what you need to
understand
is that
Dante is conveying his truth through
paradox. And you try to unravel this
paradox and the truth slowly reveals
itself to you.
Okay?
All right, let's continue.
All right.
Can you read, Ivory?
I'm sorry.
The human Charon, with his eyes like
embers, by signaling to them has all
embark. His oar strikes any anyone who
stretches out.
As in the autumn, leaves detach
themselves, first one and then the
other, till the bough sees all his
fallen garments on the ground.
Similarly, the evil seed of Adam
descended from the shoreline one by one,
when signaled, as a falcon called will
come.
So, do they move across the darkened
waters even before they reach the
farther shore, new ranks already gather
on this bank.
"My son," the gracious master said to
me,
"Those who have died beneath the wrath
of God, all these assemble here from
every country, and they are eager for
the river crossing because celestial
justice spurs them on so that their fear
is turned into desire.
No good soul ever takes this passage
passage here. Therefore, if Sharon has
complained of you, by now you can be
sure what his words mean." Okay. So, two
words that you will see a lot in Dante
are will and desire, okay?
Will and desire.
Because will and desire together create
your soul,
okay? So, in the Divine Comedy, you will
see these two words will and desire
repeated a lot. You are what you
want and what you move towards, okay?
That's ultimately your soul.
And
um
what this is telling us is that
people are evil because people obey.
Okay? Duty.
Okay? So,
this image is where the people line up
obediently and do as they're told. They
don't question why this is happening.
They don't resist why this is happening,
okay? Their will and desire is to move
towards hell.
They are not in hell because they did
bad things. Everyone does bad things.
They're in hell They're in hell because
they desire to be in hell.
Okay? And this is something that Virgil
says.
Their fear is turned into desire.
They're entering hell because they want
to do so. And this is a really important
idea if you are to understand Dante.
Free will is a fundamental truth of the
universe.
You do what you do because you choose to
do it.
You are in hell not because you did bad
things. You are in hell because you
think that hell is the best place for
you. You are happy in hell.
Okay?
All right. So, now they are in hell. And
the first place that they enter is
something called limbo. And limbo is a
place
where people go. They're good people,
but the problem is they don't believe in
Jesus. They don't believe in Christ.
They never converted to Christianity.
So, these are people like Virgil, like
Homer, like Plato. Okay? Very, very just
people, but unfortunately, they
um don't believe in God, and so
therefore, they are doomed in hell. Oh,
that's what Virgil tells Dante. Dante is
suspicious, and and Dante asks Virgil,
"Was there ever a time when people in
hell could ascend to heaven?" And Virgil
says, "There was only one time,
and that was when Jesus died, and he
came to hell
to save and redeem those most worthy.
People like King David, people like
Noah, people like Abraham, people like
Rachel, who were in the Bible, who were
born before the time of Christ,
but who are worthy of going to heaven,
and that's why Jesus came to hell.
Unfortunately, I, Virgil,
came after
uh Jesus, and so I was not saved by by
him, okay? And as you go on, you I want
you to remember this because
what we'll discover as we go on is this
is not true. It is entirely possible for
people who are not Christians,
who were born before the time of Jesus,
to ascend to heaven
because they choose to. It's about will
and desire, okay?
So, um and then they go into the first
layer of hell. And the first layer layer
of hell uh are people who lust, okay?
These are people whose passion
overrode their reason, and so they
um sinned, okay?
All right. Okay. Uh
and so, these are spirits that are
passing through, and Dante asks Virgil,
"Who are these people?" And Virgil
starts to name them one by one, okay?
Okay, can you read um Ivory?
The kindly master said, "Do not ask who
are these spirits whom you see before
you.
I'd have [snorts] you know, before you
go ahead, they did not sin, and yet,
though they have merits, that's not
enough because they lack baptism, the
portal of faith that you embrace. And if
they lived before Christianity, they did
not worship God in fitting ways, and of
such spirits I myself am one. For these
defects and for no other evil, we now
are lost and punished just with this. We
have no hope, and yet we live in
longing."
Great sorrow seized my heart on hearing
him, for I had seen some estimable men
among the souls suspended in that limbo.
>> Okay, so I want you to remember this
passage because Virgil is saying,
"There's nothing wrong with me.
Unfortunately, I'm I was just unlucky."
Okay? This is This is incorrect. What
you will see as we move on is that
Virgil chooses to be here. There are
many paths for salvation and redemption
for him, but he wants to stay in hell,
okay?
And why And why that is the case, we'll
we'll we'll talk about later.
All right. Let's keep on going.
So, I descended from the first enclosure
down to second circle, that which
girdles less space but grief more great,
that goes to weeping.
There a dreadful Minos stands,
gnashing his teeth, examining the sins
of those who enter. He judges and
assigns all as his as his tail entwines.
I mean that when the spirit born to evil
appears before him, it confesses all,
and he, the connoisseur of sin, can tell
the death in hell appropriate to it.
As many times as Minos wraps his tail
around himself, that marks the sinner's
level.
Always there is a crowd that stands
before him. Each soul in turn advances
towards the judgment. They speak and
hear, then they are cast below.
Arresting his extraordinary task, Minos,
as soon as he had seen me, said,
"Oh you who reached this house of
suffering, be careful how you enter,
whom you trust. The gate is wide, but do
not be deceived." To which my guide
replied, "But why protest? Do not
attempt to block his fated path. Our
passage has been willed above, where one
can do what he has willed, and ask no
more." Okay. So, this is a very
interesting passage that again
um makes us question things, okay? So,
Minos, who is basically deciding which
uh level of hell you go to based on your
sin, he basically says to Dante, "Don't
trust anyone here, okay? Don't trust
anyone here. Be Be careful how you
enter, whom you trust. The gate is wide,
but do not be deceived."
Okay. This is a very strange
idea, right? Because Minos sees that
Dante is with Virgil.
And his response is, "Dante,
you're a good person. I'm telling you
right now, don't trust anyone." Right?
So, what he's really saying is, "Dante,
don't trust Virgil."
Right? If you think about it logically,
makes no sense for him to say that
unless he means don't trust Virgil.
Because if Virgil can be trusted, then
all Dante has to do is just follow
Virgil into hell, and that's it, okay?
But Minos makes a point of saying,
"Don't trust anyone here." Which is to
say, "Don't trust the person closest to
you.
Be careful how you enter and whom you
trust."
Okay? And what confirms this is
To which my guide replied, "But why
protest?" Okay? So, Virgil is jumping
right in and said, "Hey, shut up, man."
Okay?
Do not attempt to block his fated path.
Our passage has been willed above, where
one can do what he has willed, and ask
no more. We are I represent a higher
power than you, Minos.
All right? So, again, this is
questioning the reliability of the
narrator. What's happening is that Dante
is planting seeds, giving us clues that
in hell, nothing is what it seems.
The person that we most trust, Virgil,
is the person that we should probably
least trust.
Okay?
All right. So, everything that Virgil
says, we have to question.
All right. So, again,
um
Virgil and Dante are in the first layer
of hell, and this is lust, and Virgil is
pointing out to Dante who they are,
okay? Can Can you read uh
Ivory?
"The first of those about whose history
you want to know," my master then told
me,
"once ruled as empress over many
nations.
Her vice of lust became so customary
that she made license licit in her laws
to free her from the scandal she had
caused.
She is Semiramis, of whom we read
[music] that she was Ninus's wife and
his successor.
She held the land [music] the Sultan now
commands.
That other spirit killed herself for
love, and she [music] and she betrayed
the ashes of Sychaeus. The wanton
Cleopatra follows next.
See Helen, who sake so many year for
whose sake so many years of evil had to
pass. See great Achilles, who finally
met love in his last battle.
See Paris, Tristan, and he points out
and names to me more than a thousand
shades departed from our life because of
love.
No sooner had I heard my teacher name
the ancient ladies and the knights than
pity seized me and I was like a man
astray. Okay, so this again is a
paradox, okay?
And again, it's almost impossible to see
this paradox by yourself.
But the paradox is this.
Um what Virgil will do is basically
point out a thousand shades, okay? He
will provide all the names of these
people. Okay, an example is
um
Semiramis
um and then you have Cleopatra, you have
Helen, you have Achilles.
You have Paris, you have Tristan. Okay,
so he's naming everyone.
But there's one shade he does not name.
And
the other spirit who killed herself for
love and she betrayed the ashes of
Sychaeus, we know who this person is
because this person is Dido.
And who is Dido?
Dido is the creation of Virgil.
So the grand paradox, the irony is
there's a thousand people and the person
that Virgil refuses to acknowledge by
name is the one
that he understands the best, who he is
most intimate with.
Okay? And look, this brings up the
question, why is this the case? Why does
he refuse to name Dido?
So if you go back to the um Aeneid
the one thing that stands out about the
Aeneid is that Dido is the most
realistic character. It's really the
character that most people when they
read the Aeneid, they sympathize with.
Because Dido feels real, but at the same
time Dido didn't really deserve her
fate, okay? So what it is Virgil
who cast Dido into hell.
Right? And this contrasts with Dante who
will elevate
Beatrice, his love
to
heaven.
All right? So already we're seeing a
contrast, a paradox.
Okay?
Virgil condemned Dido to hell, Dante
elevated Beatrice to heaven. And
Dante is longing for Beatrice
and then Virgil forgets that Dido even
existed. He even refuses to name her.
Okay, and the question then is why?
So because Dido is a realistic
character, we can assume that Dido is
based on a person that Virgil knows. But
knowing that, we can also make the
assumption that Virgil pursued
Dido, fell in love with Dido, and Dido
rejected him probably because he was an
ugly okay?
And so Virgil got really angry and
decided that I will condemn Dido to
hell.
But in his heart, Virgil knows that this
was unfair. That this was pure hatred.
And so he feels a bit guilty about it,
he feels embarrassed about it. That's
why he refuses to acknowledge Dido. He
refuses to face Dido
uh for
um
what he did, okay?
But then something interesting happens.
All right?
Okay.
Can you Can you read um
My first words, "Poet, I should
willingly speak with those two who go
together there and seem so lightly
carried by the wind."
And he to me,
"You'll see when they draw closer to us
and then you may appeal to them by that
love which impels them. They will come."
No sooner had the wind bent them towards
us than I urged on my voice.
"Oh battered souls, if one does not
forbid it, speak with us."
Even as doves when summoned by desire,
borne forward by their will, move
through the air with wings up-uplifted
still to their sweet nest, those spirits
left the ranks where Dido suffers
approaching us through the malignant
air. So powerful had been my loving cry.
Okay, so what he's saying here is that
like Virgil is naming all all the shades
and Dante is like, "Let me go and talk
to them." And Virgil says, "Sure, go
talk to them, okay?" But what I want you
to notice is this.
Those spirits left the ranks where Dido
suffers approaching us through the
malignant air, okay?
The contrast is this.
Virgil refuses to name Dido, so Dante
names Dido himself.
All right? And what this what this
really is is an act of rebellion.
Because
Dante acknowledges Virgil as his father,
as his guide, as his teacher. And
therefore, he should just follow Virgil.
If Virgil doesn't want to name Dido,
doesn't want to acknowledge Dido, then
Dante should be respectful and ignore
Dido, right?
But he's saying, "Nope, I'm going to
name Dido because I I want us to
understand that
it was wrong to not acknowledge Dido. It
was wrong, first of all, for Virgil to
condemn Dido to hell and it's wrong to
just ignore her, okay? So I know who
Dido is, I know what Virgil did, and I
want to name her
in order to resurrect her in our
memory."
All right? So again, this is creating
cognitive dissonance.
It's leaving
an idea in our heads that none of what
we're seeing in Inferno is what it
seems. That's why it's hell. It means
it's all an illusion, it's all
deception. And we have to use our minds,
we have to use our hearts to truly
understand what's going on, okay?
All right? So
this begins our journey into the Divine
Comedy. But as you can see, it is
extremely complex.
You have to see with your heart. You
have to see with your imagination. It's
impossible to just read this and know
what's going on.
You have to
>> [snorts]
>> believe in your instincts. You have to
believe in in your intuition. You have
to believe that you have connection with
God and it is God that will reveal to
you the truth through your intuition and
your imagination. Okay?
So the Divine Comedy is a journey really
into your own heart and your faith.
All right, any questions?
Okay. All right, so we will continue
this next time, okay?